[Music]
well it's the first day of spring break
for many families but it doesn't always
mean fun in the sun some students are at
risk of going hungry because they aren't
getting their meals which they often do
depend on at school Victoria Saha tells
us how other organizations though are
stepping up to help families
no child should ever have to go hungry
so the library district is offering
snacks to students so they don't have to
worry about where their next meal will
come from
at the Clark County Library snack time
is always followed by play time but play
time is never fun on an empty stomach
when you come home there's really
nothing to eat Kristin quiroz is taking
care of her little sister and just like
many her family is no stranger to food
insecurity during school breaks having
the grab-and-go meals provided by CCSD
was a huge help for her family but that
stopped after the pandemic we just try
to make ends meet when we could or
thankfully we had really good neighbors
too they'd always like be like hey do
you guys want some food Heroes is
relieved to learn many libraries are
offering free snacks to teens and young
kids this saves you a few extra dollars
to spend on other food for another time
are you enjoying your snacks what's your
favorite so far
the snacks are provided by Three Square
Food Bank to the many branches within
the library district you can definitely
tell that they might not have had a lot
for lunch or that they might not have a
lot when they get home branch manager
Robin gabler says the need doesn't seem
to go away expected to hear every day
and participating in the meal program
you know it's definitely needed although
the turnout is different each day the
library district is always prepared
Victoria Saha 8 News Now
now keep in mind the kids Cafe will be
open every day this week at the Clark
County Library the program is also
spread out though across four other
libraries but the times and the days are
different so for a complete list we have
that for you on our website at
8newsnow.com